هذه المراه الليبيه متزوجه برجل غير لي به
منذ ما يقارب 25 عاما لا يمكنها ثوره
املاكها لابنائها الاربعه لان القانون
الليبي يمن واصحاب الجنسيات الاخرى من
التملك حتى وان كانوا من ام ليبيه ولا
يخول لهم الحصول على جنسيته والدتهم
علاج لا مش ليبي حق التملك كيف صغار
خلاص
قررت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه منح ابناء
الليبيات مجانيه العلاج والتعليم في
الداخل والخارج والدخول الى الاراضي
الليبيه بدون تاشيره سفر
قديم مستوى القاعده القانونيه او القاعده
الدستوريه
انهم يزيدوا يتوسعوا في هذا القرار بحيث
ان حتى
يمنعوهمحوهم الجنسيه
وجدلوا شرعيه الاجسام الموجوده حائقا في
تنفيذ مثل هذه القرارات على كل البلاد
ومنافذها الحدوديه
فقط وهذا القرار لا يسري على حق الانتقام
اشتريته القانون الليبيه على المراه التي
ترغب الزواج برجل لا يحمل الجنسيه الليبيه
الحصول على موافقه وزاره الشؤون
الاجتماعيه
ويقدر عدد المتحصلات على هذه الموافقه
بحوالي
15,000 امراه
قرار يصفه مؤيدوه بالخطبه في الاتجاه
الصحيحه حتى وان جاء متاخرا فيما يرى
البعض الاخر انه لم يرتقي الى سقف المطامع
وتظل قانونيه القرار محل جدلا لدى
الكثيرين منير الاشهر طلب العربيه